bonsoir tout le monde comment allez-vous
nouveau serait d'horreur trois histoires
encore une fois peut-être qu'un jour je
repris des vidéos comme à l'époque où on
traiter qu'une seule histoire dans une
vidéo de 15 minutes mais d'un autre côté
les histoires qui font peur chacun est
sensible à des mécaniques quelques
différends qu'ils aiment bien offert
trois comme sachez que tout le monde a
été touché par au moins l'une des trois
aujourd'hui au rendez-vous la première
est folle la deuxième est très
différente de ce qu'on a pu voir
habituellement c'est vraiment celle où
est la troisième est un peu plus
classique mais chez pas c'est très bien
racontée et il ya un peu de
rebondissements un moment fait j'aime
bien et attention aujourd'hui ce ne sont
que des histoires qui sont arrivés à des
francophones à une belge plus
précisément et à deux français donc vous
n'êtes pas à l'abri attention on
commence donc avec notre ami belge elena
qui a maintenant 28 ans mais qui en
avait 18 ans au moment des faits
situation classique elena est invité par
une amie à elle à une soirée sauf que la
soirée se situe à une heure de chez elle
donc elle a un peu la flemme sachant
qu'en plus de ça elle connaît personne à
la soirée à par l'ami qui l'invitent et
vous savez ces moments où t'as pas trop
envie de se sociabiliser on connaît elle
finit quand même par se motiver et par y
aller et devinez quoi la soirée se passe
très bien elle s'amuse bien et surtout
elle ne boit pas puisqu'elle est venue
en voiture et elles comptent rentrer
chez elle le soir même en toute sûreté
il est 4 heures du matin c'est la fin de
la soirée et elle rejoint sa voiture qui
est une vieille voiture des années 90
qu'elle a acheté avec son salaire de job
d'étudiant mais sa voiture n est pas
garer sur le trottoir juste en bas de la
soirée parce que la soirée a eu lieu
dans une vieille distillerie du coup il
ya quelques minutes de marche à faire
pour qu'elle rejoigne sa voiture sachant
que on à la campagne c'est pas éclairé
donc déjà il ce chien peut tuer les non
mais si rien par rapport à ce qui arrive
elle arrive finalement devant sa voiture
elle met sa clé dans la portière et la
petite clim la voiture était déjà
déverrouiller et les knights dit attends
bizarre j'ai jamais oublié de
verrouiller ma voiture bon ça peut
arriver heureusement personne me la
voler elle s'assoit à la place du
conducteur elle pose son sac à main à la
place du passager avant et puis en
posant son sac à main du coin de l'oeil
elle voit des jambes sur sa banquette
arrière
ce truc là je les ai vu que dans des
films perso alors ils n'eurent pas elle
se retourne et elle voit une femme
allongée sur sa banquette arrière
screamer elena évidemment est terrifié
donc elle lui hurle dessus et lui
demande qu'est ce qu'elle fout sur sa
banquette arrière la fille du coup
sursaute sous les cris d'elena elle
s'excuse et à lui expliquer la situation
en fait cette fille était elle aussi
invitée à la même soirée qu'elena elle y
est allée en train pas en voiture sauf
qu'au moment de partir elle a raté le
dernier train retour et donc elle a
décidé de rentrer dans la première
voiture déverrouiller qu'elle croisait
pour y dormir et y passer la nuit face à
ces explications évidemment l ena elle
s'en veut lui avoir collé dessus pour se
rattraper elle propose à cette fille de
l'arast et chez elle sympa la ln elle
invite donc à s'asseoir devant avec elle
et c'est parti pour la ramener à la
maison et au fil de la discussion la fiq
est assez à côté d'elle elle se met un
peu à se contredire dans ce qu'elle dit
comme si elle s'invente est une vie mais
heureusement après quelques minutes de
route elle arrive enfin sur des routes
un peu moins rurales et des trucs un peu
plus éclairés malheureusement maintenant
qu'elle n' avons un petit peu mieux la
fille à côté d'elle dans la voiture
grâce à la lueur des éclairages de la
route elle remarque que les jambes de la
fille qu'elle est en train de ramener
chez elle sont extrêmement poilus mais
poilu comme les jambes d'un homme pas
d'une femme qui s'épilent réparé à tel
point qu'il est n'a réalise qu'en fait
la fille qu'elle est en train de ramener
chez elle est un homme qui prétend est
une fille pour des raisons qu'elle
ignore à l'heure actuelle mais des
raisons qui sont probablement
malveillantes au vu de toutes les
contradictions qui avait dans son
discours est d'à quel point la personne
par étendue comme si elle s'apprêtait à
faire un truc pas bien du tout elena
être terrorisé évidemment mais en même
temps elle est bloquée dans une voiture
à 100 km/heure avec cette personne donc
si elle commence à paniquer allure
lecture lui demandant des explications
elle a peur de créer une réaction
agressive chez cette personne bref c'est
la merde et c'est donc tout
naturellement qu'elena va volontairement
provoqué un petit accident
un petit accident de sorte à ce que
personne ne soit blessé mais qui
justifie le fait qu elena appelle la
police trop mal elena s'excuse elle dit
merde j'ai perdu le contrôle de la
voiture je suis désolée elle prétendait
dessous chocs alors qu'en fait elle est
surtout sous le choc d'être seul au
milieu de nulle part avec cet inconnu
est ludique la voiture est endommagée
que elle doit donc appelé la police et
en lui disant ça l'inconnu avec elle lui
dit tout de suite n'ont pas besoin
d'appeler la police j'ai un ami qui
habite pas loin je vais l'appeler il va
bien nous aider ce qui est clairement le
pire truc est avec l'inconnu 10 à ce
moment là sauf que pendant que l'inconnu
lui répondait ça elena elle avait déjà
tapé les 17es était déjà en train
d'appeler et heureusement la police a
répondu immédiatement elle commence donc
à leur parler au téléphone et elle a à
peine le temps de leur dire de phrase
qu'on se retournant elle voit que
l'inconnu est en train de partir en
courant à ce moment-là elena comprend
donc qu'elle était bel et bien en danger
et que cette personne était mal
intentionnés et elle fond en larmes elle
explique tout à la police hier au bout
du fil qui lui explique qu'une équipe
est juste à côté d'elle et d'ici cinq
minutes elle devrait sur les lieux la
police arrive sur les lieux et les nike
caché derrière sa voiture elle avait
très très peur pendant ces cinq minutes
que l'inconnu reviennent peut être
accompagnée de son fameux amis et donc à
leur explique tout et puis la police
décide de fouiller la voiture d'elena au
cas où il ya des éléments qui leur
permettent de retrouver l'individu il
ouvre le coffre et en découvrant ce
qu'il ya dans son coffre et les mares se
décompose parce qu'à l'intérieur se
trouve une bâche et une pelle c'est bon
en voyant ça la police dia lna en fait
là vous avez eu énormément de chance là
le petit incident que vous venez de
provoquer et qui a justifié votre appel
à la police il vient de vous sauver la
vie littéralement ce soir là
heureusement l ena ranch est elle saine
et sauve mais elles restent terrorisés
par ce qu'elle a vécu avec cette
inconnue et surtout elle fait partie des
gens qui n'ont pas eu d'explication
c'est à dire qu'elle ne l'a jamais revue
elle n'a plus jamais entendu parler de
lui elena précise aussi et c'est
important de le préciser qu'elle a rien
du tout contre les transgenres et
transsexuels les travestis peu importe l
explique jusqu'à ce moment-là elle a
compris que cette personne là ne faisait
pas partie de cette catégorie de
personnes et qu'il s'agissait juste d'un
mec vulgairement déguisés en femmes dans
le but que ses futures victimes baissent
leur garde et qu'il puisse leur faire du
mal plus facilement bref c'est la fin de
cette première histoire et devinez quoi
elle me met particulièrement mal parce
que j'ai un peu ce traumatisme de la
banquette arrière à cause de plein de
films que j'ai vus ou souvent quand je
retourne ma voiture dans un parking je
colle ma vitre à la fenêtre arrière pour
être sûr qu'il y ait personne dedans et
si je vois un visage bajur pas je laisse
la voiture je l'abandonnent jeu par
messieurs dames il est temps de passer à
la deuxième histoire et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi j'ai choisi rémy vit
seule chez sa mère depuis toujours dans
sa ville natale une petite ville de
province dans laquelle il a fait ses
études sauf que là il entre dans sa
quatrième année d'études il doit donc
trouver un stage et il a trouvé un stage
en marketing dans une ville un peu plus
loin que sa ville natale du coup deux
options s'offrent à lui la première la
moins pratique c'est de rester vivre
chez sa mère et de faire 1h30 de trajet
chaque matin et chaque soir pour se
rendre sur son lieu de stage la deuxième
option qui est sans doute la plus
pratique c'est de trouver un logement
près de l'entreprise de manière à éviter
de se taper le trajet tous les jours et
ya aussi quelque chose qui penche en
faveur de cette deuxième option c'est le
fait qu'un ancien ami de sa mère est
propriétaire d'une maison trois pièces
juste à côté de l'entreprise dans
laquelle rémy fait son stage bref tout
ça le fait pencher définitivement en
faveur de cette deuxième option et rémy
prend son nouveau départ la première
semaine est difficile il est seul dans
une maison qui est à moitié vide il a
pas encore eu le temps de ramener toutes
ces affaires de chez sa mère et donc le
week-end suivant il décide d'aller
adopter un chat pour avoir de
l'accompagner se sentir moins seuls et
décide de l'appeler car oui et c'est là
que l'histoire commence vraiment la
deuxième semaine rémy rencontre simon
simon habite la maison d'à côté il a la
trentaine il fait près de 100 kilos il
en impose mais rémy explique que chez
pas six mois a l'air sympa il a un
visage un peu nier ce qui le rend
sympathique un peu méchant de dire ça on
est d'accord le week end arrive et rémy
cas pas envie d'être seule pour le
week-end le patch et sa mère et en
rentrant chez sa mère dimanche soir en
arrivant sur son palier rémy découvre
une bière fraîche posez la sur son
paillasson avec un petit mot sur lequel
la marque est situé en veut d'autres tu
sais où trouver clin d'oeil simon mais
quelle chic voisins ceux ci m'ont
ils se recroisent à l'occasion d'une
balade de rémy avec k oui oui balade son
chat ça fait rire simon qui lui dit en
retour de faire bien attention à son
chat parce qu'il ya eu pas mal de
disparitions de chats ces derniers mois
dans le quartier et c'est effectivement
ce que rémy a remarqué en baladant son
char à savoir des avis de disparition a
pas mal d'endroits c'est donc tout
naturellement que plus le temps passe
plus rémy a confiance en simon et en
plus de ça car oui aime bien simon et ça
les propriétaires d'animaux vous le
savez ça nous touche qu'on être animal
il aime bien quelqu'un et que ça se voit
on a naturellement encore plus confiance
en ce quelqu'un à force de se croiser et
rémy en a appris un peu plus sur simon
normale et il serait apparemment un
ancien cariste au chômage depuis
plusieurs mois qui serait en train de
monter sa propre affaire le temps passe
les semaines passent cawi sort
maintenant tout seul de la maison et
revient tous les soirs et durant ces
semaines rémy remarque un truc bizarre
et remarques souvent la journée il ya
pas mal de gens qui passent dans la
maison mais y'a pas simon il en aurait
donc parlé à simon lors de leur
rencontre et simon avait expliqué sa
part le fait qu'en fait c'est pas sa
maison à lui c'est celle de son père et
elle est en vente depuis un moment ce
qui explique que ya pas mal de passages
à l'intérieur la journée passage de
futurs acheteurs mais un jour problème
contrairement à tous les autres matin
car oui n'est pas rentré chez lui dans
un premier temps ça va pas du tout
inquiète et d'amis qui se dit bon c'est
pas grave je vais aller au travail et il
va probablement rentrer dans la journée
sauf qu'en rentrant du travail à 17
heures il n'y a toujours pas de cas oui
à la maison ce soir là rémy doit aller
chez sa nouvelle copine dont il est
apparemment très amoureux mais suite à
la disparition de kawawii il va
l'appeler pour lui expliquer que il
annule il a clairement pas la tête à ça
alors qu'il vient de perdre son animal
il tombe donc chez simon est la chose
qui lui est jamais arrivé avant il
attend une minute avant que simon
viennent y ouvrir et rémy remarque tout
de suite quelque chose de chelou sexy
mila des gants en latex noir en voyant
rémy simon il a l'air vachement surpris
il a pas l'air à l'aise du tout et
instinctivement il fait rentrer rémy
chez lui et en rentrant chez lui rémy
ressent un truc bizarre puisque tout est
vide simon commencent à engager une
discussion très green avait créé mais
une discussion qu'on sent un peu forcé
et pendant qu'il lui parle hirgars rémy
droit dans les yeux comme pour essayer
de voir si dans son regard rémy
acquiesce et croit à ce qu'il dit au
bout d'un moment rémy pose sa main sur
l'épaule de simon et lui dit écoute je
suis là parce que ce soir je dois aller
chez ma copine mais j'ai un problème et
il n'a pas le temps de finir son
explication
l'entente des griffures contre la porte
de l'une des deux chambres fermées simon
remarquerez me regarde en direction de
la chambre fermée là il ya un blanc un
blanc qui se termine par la sonnerie du
téléphone de rémy parce que sa copine
l'appel rémy décroche et fait signe à
simon que c'est un coup de fil important
et qui va sur le perron pour y répondre
et sur le perron rémy fait un truc très
mal et commence à discuter avec sa
copine au bout du fil et lui dit écoute
je dois régler un truc avant de venir je
serais sûrement un peu en retard
actuellement je suis chez si monde c'est
le voisin dont j'étais par les jeux
devraient régler ça assez rapidement
mais c'est apanews d'ici une demi heure
c'est qu'il ya un problème on est
clairement sur une master class et en
rentrant dans la maison et tombe sur
simon qui tient qu'à oui dans ses bras
sauf que cawi n'est pas en mode qu'alain
là il a les poils hérissés il est
terrorisé il a clairement peur de simon
simon prend tout de suite la parole et
lui explique que kamui est venu gratter
à sa porte en pleine nuit et que donc
tout naturellement il lui a ouvert et il
a accueilli et puis immédiatement il
tente de justifier l'état de kawawii en
lui expliquant qu'il a dû faire des
travaux dans la maison il a dû percer
des trucs et c est que le bruit a dû
énormément stressé cawi d'où son état
bref rémy comprend que il ya un énorme
blême il récupère cas oui et il va avec
son chat chez sa copine à partir de là
pendant deux semaines rémy ne va plus
croisés si vous une après-midi rémy voit
une nouvelle fois du monde à l'intérieur
de la maison et décide ce jour la dalle
est ok pour leur parler ou plus tôt pour
parler à la personne qu'il pense être le
père de simon et lors de cette
discussion rémy découvre la vérité cet
homme déjà lui explique qu'il n'a pas
d'enfant ce n'est pas le père de su en
revanche il lui confirme que c'est bel
et bien sa maison à lui et qu'il a fait
faire des travaux d'aménagement il ya de
ça quelques mois rémy lui explique
l'histoire et lui des crises cible est
immédiatement l'homme voit de qui il
parle la description physique que lui
fait rémy correspond à celle d'un
ouvrier qui serait venu poser du
carrelage il ya déjà plusieurs mois
n'étant pas content du travail effectué
et le propriétaire se seraient plaints
auprès de l'entreprise et le patron
l'entreprise de travaux lui aurait
expliqué que c'est pas le premier client
qui se plaint du travail de cet ouvrier
et qu'il allait le renvoyer pour faute
professionnelle
rémy les propriétaires comprennent donc
que simon a gardé un double des clés
après s'être fait renvoyer est venu
dormir là sans aucune autorisation rémy
est choqué mais à partir de là il ne
croise plus simon et les prochaines news
qui va avoir de lui ces quelques mois
plus tard il aurait appris que simon se
serait fait arrêter par la police dans
un village voisin après avoir essayé
d'enlever un chien en plaine la police
aurait révélé plus tard que simon se
trouve être en fait un psychopathe qui
trouveraient du plaisir sexuel dans la
torture d'animaux il n'aurait en
revanche à moins qu'on n'est pas encore
découvert jamais franchi le pas sur le
meurtre du main rémy est quand même
content d'avoir croisé simon parce que
lors de toutes leurs discussions de
voisins quand ils se croisaient simon
lui donner de bons conseils pour aller
séduire la fille qui lui plaisait tant
au travail qui est devenue sa copine et
qu'il est toujours au moment où il
raconte cette histoire bref il arrive à
en tirer du positif et pour ça respect
rémy et merci pour ton histoire mais ce
drame il est maintenant temps de passer
à la dernière histoire celle de aldric
qui est mon pire cauchemar et le vôtre
aussi quelques années avant de raconter
cette histoire adriq fait une norme
soirée avec des potes à lui et aldric
quand c'est une fin de soirée peu
importe l'heure qu'il est il veut
rentrer chez lui pour dormir dans son
lit il a un peu la flemme de dormir par
terre chez un pote dans le canapé normal
il habite à la campagne don qui marche
dans des zones qui sont très peu éclairé
il passe à côté des champs etc mais tout
se passe bien pendant un kilomètre et il
précise même si c'est pas bien qu'au
moment où ça arrive on est encore en
pleine période de couvre-feu c'est à
dire que dehors il ya vraiment personne
exi à quelqu'un tu es pas rassuré bref
après tout les petits chemins de
campagne agri qui arrive enfin dans une
rue qui est normalement très légèrement
éclairé mais là elle est beaucoup plus
éclairés qu'habituellement parce que
dans cette rue se trouve une voiture
avec les pleins phares allumés et aldric
il aperçoit trois personnes dedans ou
plutôt trois silhouettes ya pas assez de
lumière pour distinguer les visages et
pour une fois un meurtre et d'horreur va
faire ce que nous on aurait fait adri
qui part en courant ciao et pendant
qu'ils coup il entend que la voiture
maintenant ne roule plus doucement elle
accélère plein bal à ce moment là en
plein sprint aldrin qui se dit ok je
suis mort je vais faire dépouiller et
puis à un moment donné se retourne et
ils voient que sur la voiture se trouve
un gyrophare alors aldric tu es juste
dehors en plein couvre-feu sous l'effet
de l'alcool et de la weed tout va bien
il se fait donc contrôlée par la bac il
leur explique qu'il était une soirée à
telle adresse qu il rentre chez lui à
telle adresse qu il est vrai ils bravent
le couvre-feu et c'est pas bien il en
est désolé il a un peu d'huile sur lui
en plus aldric la bac juste l'apprend
les crasses par terre et ne lui en tient
pas rigueur les policiers sont montrés
compréhensifs ils mettent pas d'amande
et le mettre en garde à vue ils lui
disent juste bon frérot rentre chez toi
c'est bon c'est pas le meilleur retour
de soirée de samedi clermont mais après
ça c'est le torse bombé et très sereine
qu'elle brigue reprend la direction de
chez lui ils marchent pendant quelques
minutes et là il ressent un truc étrange
autour de lui vous savez ce fameux
instinct août essence te disent t'es
peut-être pas seul était peut-être même
observer il se retourne mais voit rien à
part une rue légèrement éclairé des
poubelles des devant d'habitation n'y a
rien de spécial il se dit donc qu'il est
très certainement d'être parano à cause
de la weed qu'il a fumé pendant toute la
soirée ils décident quand même qu'à
partir de là il ne va emprunter que des
rues éclairées même si ça va lui faire
faire des détours et retardé fortement
son heure d'arrivée à la maison alors
qu'il est déjà très tard et il fait bien
parce que deux minutes plus tard il
entend un boum et en se retournant il
voit une silhouette se cacher derrière
des poubelles à partir de là il a donc
bel et bien la confirmation qu'il est
suivi et continuer à marcher il sent
toujours qu'il est suivi et cette fois
il entend un bruit métallique
encore une fois il ya deux options à
partir de là pour aldric soit il prétend
s'en [ __ ] et continue de marcher
tranquillement en restant vigilant au
bruit derrière lui soit il prend la
fuite sauf qu'il a déjà pris la fuite
une fois ce soir et son cardio il est
bousillée ce qui va faire à la place
c'est du génie il va sortir son
téléphone est allé sur disque hand et
heureusement il ya deux potes à lui qui
sont en train de jouer à league of
legends tout en marchant à greek leur
envoie un message et leur dis les gars
venaient visio c'est urgent
immédiatement les deux amis ils
rejoignent ils sont donc comment
fessetime sur discorde et aldric à voix
très basse leur explique qu'il pense
être suivie par quelqu'un et qu'il a
besoin de leur aide tout en marchant
élèves donc son téléphone en faisant le
geste de quand tu cherches du réseau de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent voir ce qui
se trouve derrière aldric via la caméra
de l'iphone et puis 6 secondes plus tard
ils leur baisse hélas le visage de ses
deux amis a changé et l'un des deux va
rompent le silence en dix ans on a bien
vu ce qu'on a vu là il demande donc à
ses deux amis de leur expliquer ce
qu'ils viennent de voir et mieux que des
explications l'un de ses deux amis à
screen est ce qu'il a vu à l'image
aldric regarde la photo est ce qu'il y
découvre va le mettre dans une panique
totale puisqu'il y découvre un homme a à
peu près 20 mètres de lui qui tient dans
la main un énorme couteau de boucher
encore une fois aldric n'a plus de
cardio il se dit que si ce n'est à
sprinter il aura que 20 secondes de
sprint à dispo et que donc ça doit être
les 20 dernières secondes de son trajet
avant d'arriver chez lui son plan est
simple il veut passer devant la gare de
sa ville parce qu'il sait qu'il ya des
caméras qui filment l'extérieur et s'il
doit lui arriver intrus il veut que ce
mec passe devant ses caméras de
surveillance il va donc marcher pendant
de longues minutes avant de passer
devant la gare tout en ne sachant pas
s'il est toujours suivi ou pas puisqu'il
ya plus de bruit qui proviennent de
derrière lui et puis à l'entrée de son
quartier pavillonnaire il va sprinter de
toutes ses formes jusqu'à sa maison
arrivé chez lui immédiatement il vire où
toutes les serrures il va dans sa
chambre et fait un truc qui l'a jamais
fait avant ils activent la larme de sa
maison via son téléphone alors qu'il est
dans la maison au moins si le mec l'a
suivie jusque là et qui veut rentrer
chez lui il n'y a pas doute il sera
averti la aldric explique un truc assez
touchant il dit écoute j'ai pas vraiment
lu ça dans l'est serait de voir que j'ai
pu lire mais moi sachez qu'à ce moment
là quand je suis dans mon lit et que
j'active l alarme je fonds en larmes je
chiale de toutes mes forces le lendemain
adriq se réveille et premier truc qui
fait il va au commissariat la policière
prend sa déposition aldric rendent chez
lui et après quelques heures seulement
la police hier le rappel la policière
lui explique qu'elle a récupéré les
images de toutes les caméras de
surveillance que aldric a croisé sur son
chemin et elle lui explique qu
effectivement très peu de temps après
son contrôle de police un individu avec
une énorme arme blanche à la main s'est
mis à le poursuivre sur les images on le
voit fréquemment se cacher quand aldric
ralentit ou s'arrête où se retourne et
lui dit qu'il a arrêté de le suivre au
moment où il arrivait dans son quartier
pavillonnaire et qu'il a sprinté comme
un fou aldric il est choqué de malades
mais d'un autre côté il est rassuré il
n'a pas fait un bad trip la veille il
était bel et bien en danger il a bel et
bien eu conscience du danger qui
l'entouraient et il en tire une seule
leçon il ne rentrera plus jamais de
soirée à pied seul en pleine nuit et je
pense que c'est une bonne leçon
messieurs dames on arrive à la fin de ce
serait d'horreur j'espère qu'il vous a
plu je trouve ces trois histoires
excellent ça se trouve ce serait
d'horreur ont aidé certains parmi vous à
ne pas se trouver dans des situations
roule ou de malades et ça ça me fait
plaisir bref à bientôt ses prochaines
vidéos bisous de squeeze hausse à
salbris pu m'arrêter tvo l'emprunt
ma mère ça me fait ch et quand on va le
faire sortir toi que j'ai vieilli
les parts les animaux mac nord comme en
été 2007 est pas tout à fait des abdos
cowboys